[Music]
subordinating your ego is actually the
ultimate form of self-confidence
that level of confidence earns respects
so when i prepare
i know what i'm capable of doing i know
what i'm comfortable doing and i know
what i'm not comfortable doing
action is what builds confidence it
doesn't start with belief
wanna be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you're
capable of more
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today
let's live your best believe life and
learn the six
simple but powerful ways to develop
massive confidence
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with way number
one subordinate
your ego with jackal willing
subordinating your ego is actually the
ultimate form of self-confidence
that level of confidence earns respects
earns respect
so while the initial thought or feeling
might be that you back down
you've actually shown that you have the
strength and confidence to give the
other person credit
and they will recognize and respect that
confidence either
consciously or subconsciously
they feel it they feel it echo charles
when you're getting ready to roll jiu
jitsu and you
have never rolled with this person
before and you lock up with them
you know right you can feel it now
whether you want to admit it or not
you know yeah and that's what this does
when someone says hey you know what go
ahead and run with that
and dave might think well that's right
that's right i'm going to run with it
because my plan is better and in the
back of his mind
he thinks man yeah like when someone
says oh
you want to start a cross side that's
basically what you're saying that's
basically what you're saying
you want to start in a dominant position
go ahead it's fine it's fine with me
i'm so confident in my jiu jitsu that
you can basically start anywhere you can
start in a totally dominant position
and i'm going to be fine when you subdue
your ego and you subordinate your ego
that person now that per you might be
thinking oh yeah i'm going to start on
the mao and i'm going to kill you
and you think that right and you feel
powerful but in the back of your mind
you're thinking
maybe subconsciously you're thinking wow
this person is
confident this person knows that they're
going to win
yeah and so that's the same thing that
happens here hey
you know what why don't you take don't
you go ahead and run with this yeah
that's right i won
and in the back your mind you think man
jacko doesn't even really yeah he
doesn't even care what this ends up and
check this out
if you're reading this and you're going
i don't want to subordinate my ego
because i'm powerful then read the next
part which says if you're truly powerful
you've got no problem doing this guess
what hey you know what
i don't need to be the i don't need to
be the star of the show because i'm just
going to be over here and it's going to
be fine you guys can you can you can pay
attention to the other guys that's cool
i'll be over here just
and i'm good with that i don't need to
say anything
i don't need to start in the best
position
i'm good i'm confident i've been doing
this game for a long time
we're good way number two prepare with
kobe bryant
to me the mentality is a really simple
one
in the sense that the confidence comes
from preparation
you know so when the game's on the line
i'm not asking myself to do something
that i haven't done
thousands of times before right so when
i prepare i know what i'm capable of
doing
i know what i'm comfortable doing and i
know what i'm not comfortable doing
all right and so in those moments if it
looks like um ice cold or
not nervous it's because i've done it
thousands of times before
so it's one more time way number three
tie your win
to others with rachel hollis who needs
it
more than you who needs this win more
than you
meaning i have four kids i have all
these employees
it's not about me it's about them
and so often especially for women
i think that if you can tie it to
something
greater than yourself you know everyone
talks about the why and simon sinek
what's your why
and that's great but it's like it's not
for me it's not
what's my why it's what's my who who
needs this more than i need this
um and other people are counting on me
to be strong
and often i think when you don't have
the courage in yourself
you can find the courage for other
people like you've ever
heard those stories where like a parent
will like lift a
car off their child who's been pinned
underneath it
yeah it's you will find a [ __ ] way
when it's for someone else also if you
want to have more self-confidence and
self-belief check out my 254 series
where every day for the next 254 days
i will send you an unlisted video the
sign says it takes up to 254 days
of consecutive action build a habit so
i'm going to be with you every step of
the way
if you want to be on for free 100 free
is the link below
go check it out i'll see you there the
skill to hold your opinions to yourself
until everyone has spoken
does two things your life journey is
about learning to become more of who you
are and fulfilling the highest
truest expression of yourself as a human
being
if you're still saying that to yourself
over and over and over again and you're
complaining
it's what you're really good at is
ignoring your gut and so it's time to
start tuning into your gut and making
some changes
way number four align your actions with
your beliefs with oprah winfrey
many of you as i have been as i am
are where you are in your life based
upon what you believe
and it's not just what you think you
believe on the surface
it's also your shadow beliefs that are
holding you back
from moving into the life that you
believe
you deserve what i know is if you're not
looking at the shadows if you're not
looking at what is
subconsciously running through the tape
in your mind
telling yourself you're not good enough
you're not worthy enough you're not
smart enough
you're not enough which is a tape that's
playing for a lot of people
if you're not conscious of that then you
end up
acting out of that belief system and not
out of what
you know to be the truest or want to be
the truest
for yourself but you don't become what
you want because so much of wanting is
about
living in the space of what you don't
have that's why jim carrey's story
is so powerful because he started to act
as though he already had it
he would go up to mulholland drive he
would drive away saying
thinking i already have those things i
just haven't accessed them as yet
i believe those things are going to come
to me and i'm going to act
like they are so i'm going to move
forward in my life in order to
draw that to myself in such a way that
my
actions are in alignment with what i say
i believe so if you start to think about
that really
why are you where you are in your life
the choices that you have made
have been because of what you believe to
be true for yourself
way number five be willing to try with
mel robbins
we've bought into a lie that confidence
is belief in self
and so when you're in a situation which
is normal where you don't believe in
yourself you're like oh my god i have no
confidence the truth is and i want you
to walk out of here with a new
definition of confidence
confidence is the willingness to try
because when you try and you take action
what happens and what's happened for
france is that
when she sees herself taking action
what happens is she sees herself being
the kind of person that takes action so
she has
evidence that she can rely on herself
and that action is what builds
confidence
it doesn't start with belief the real
way
the real way for most of us is not to
wait to believe but to push ourselves to
act
and through the action you will build
the belief and way number six the last
one before a very special bonus clip
is understand that you are not the
problem
with simon sinek no one is no one is
born with self-confidence
zero right every single one of us our
self-confidence was determined by how we
were raised
the parents we had the teachers we had
the bosses we've had the jobs we've had
my sister worked for a company for 17
years and her boss
destroyed her self-confidence she came
out of that job and she didn't realize
until she got into her new job
how afraid she was to make decisions
because of her boss
and it took it took a while for her to
get her confidence back
um and so if somebody's insecure we have
to over and over and over again
prove to them because we don't know
where they came from we don't know
what kind of trouble they got in before
for being honest right
or what how they were raised we don't
know
and so we have to total empathy and just
prove to them
that that if they make a mistake they're
going to get helped not hurt
they're going to get supported not
yelled at and it the first time they
won't believe you they think it's a game
they think it's a con
it's a trick the second time maybe
and we just have to keep at it that
every time i used to have i used to have
somebody on my team
who would regularly lie to me right
because she would rather lie to me
than tell me that she made a mistake it
was in
and i could and if i saw the lie i would
ask so many questions together to
say to me i screwed up i'd be like well
this doesn't make sense
because i can't say you're lying to me
right i just say this doesn't make sense
this doesn't make sense if this adds up
to this then why is it that
and she would the lie would get bigger
and then she would yell at me
about how i don't trust her and then at
the end i have to be like listen
it clearly doesn't add up i'm okay
if it doesn't add up if you made a
mistake just tell me how
i'm good we'll move on but when you
deceive me i'm going to ask you so many
questions to get to the truth
that it's going to get worse and worse
and worse i had to have that
conversation with her
probably 50 times before little cracks
started
to show where she showed up to me once
where one number wasn't there
and she looked at me and said i made a
mistake and i went cool thanks
well alan mulley puts it brilliantly he
says you
you have a problem you are not the
problem
right so if something goes wrong we have
a problem but you are not the problem
and that's the point is we've too many
times told people that they're the
problem
so i think it's just going to take time
and patience and you have to do the hard
work of helping that person build up
their confidence again now i've got a
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action for
the next week
when you watch a video and you get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of following through that's not
enough but when you write down what time
what place and how you're going to
actually take action on it
you jump to 91 chance of following
through and when you have public
accountability and you commit
to other people that you're going to do
it it jumps to 95
that you will follow through so i want
that for you believe nation
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you you're your biggest critic i think
most people would be their own biggest
critic right now
but you're not your biggest fan you have
to be both at the same time
the amount that you criticize yourself
needs to be balanced with an equal
amount of love
all of the the critique that i want like
tell me i suck tell me my videos suck
tell me how to get better
it's all based off of i love what i do i
think i have the greatest channel on
youtube
i think i'm amazing right it's all the
foundation of love
that then it's easy to take to criticism
but when you're being criticized
and you're criticizing yourself and you
don't love yourself at the same time
that's destructive it's negative it goes
deeper it goes darker
right so i think i think most people
could actually handle more
self-criticism
i think you should be even harder on
yourself
but you have to come way up on the
self-love side
you need to learn to be your biggest
critic as well as your biggest
fan
[Music]
if you want to learn the habits that
will make you confident and outgoing
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there if you tell yourself a story long
enough you start to believe it once you
believe it you act like it
didn't call on anybody for a year
because i was literally
frozen in fear if you're nervous